Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking. No else.
You were posting a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies.com this is the training
system that I am most obsessed with
at the moment and I don't get paid any
commissions or anything like that.
You may have heard coach summer on
the podcast who designed the program,
former national team coach
for men's gymnastics.
I am not easily impressed at and I've
just been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming
and the elegance of his programming.
I've been using gymnastic bodies for
just a few months now and I feel more
flexible,
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear myself
say that,
but it's true.
That's the hardest part to
believe and you can check it out.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash.
Tim, if you go to that landing page,
gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim
you can take a look at the fundamentals
course, which I'll help you diagnose
your weakest points, areas to improve,
et Cetera,
and I highly encourage you take a look
at this bodyweight training system.
It is incredible.
Gymnastic bodies.com forward slash Tim.
Okay,
this podcast is brought
to you by trunk club.
I hate shopping with a passion and you
guys know this and I'm honestly not any
good at it anyway, which means I end up
looking like I'm colorblind or homeless.
This is where trunk club comes in,
which provides you with your own personal
stylist and makes it easier than ever
to shop for clothes that
look great on your body.
Even if you suck at picking clothing,
just go to trunk club.com forward slash
Tim and answer a few questions and then
you'll be sent a trunk full of awesome
clothes. They base this on your sizes,
preferences, all that jazz. The trunk is
then delivered free of charge both ways,
so you only pay for clothes that you keep.
So you have prepaid stickers and whatnot.
If you keep none, it costs you nothing.
It's super easy. Trunk Club is not a
subscription service I wanted to avoid.
There are no monthly fees. Also want
to avoid that your stylist is free.
Shipping is always free and you
have 10 days to try on the clothes.
Risk free and trunk club
is backed by Nordstrom,
which means they have
the highest standards and
quality and customer service.
If you care about saving
time or looking good,
check it out@trunkclub.com
forward slash Tim again,
that's truck club.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where
it is usually my job to deconstruct
world class performers to tease apart the
habits, routines,
favorite books, et Cetera,
dozens of things so that you can act on
from people ranging from chess prodigies
to four star generals.
Special OPS commander is to everybody
in between professional athletes,
you name it.
In this particular episode,
we have an in between a sewed
with Seth Goden, his last episode,
which covers a lot of his
bio and everything else. We
really dug into the weeds.
Super Fun is long. That one was
about two, two and a half hours long.
This one is short,
it's about 30 minutes long and you can
think of it as philosophical steroids.
I listened to this. It takes a couple
minutes to get warmed up, so be patient.
But there are some incredible gems and
I listened to a few times including how
to keep track of the right things and
creating a narrative that serves you as
opposed to handicaps you.
It's very, very simple,
but it's a foundational
skill and mindset that I
try to practice myself.
And this was a fantastic reminder there.
Just some really pithy,
actionable things that you can implement.
Uh,
and I would suggest that you
reflect on in journaling and so on.
Seth is the author of 17
bestselling books. He is at,
this is sets blog on Twitter.
They've been translated
into more than 35 languages.
He writes about the way ideas spread,
marketing, strategic quitting leadership,
and most of all challenging the status
quo in all areas. His books include,
and I'm sure many of you have read
more than one linchpin tribes,
the dip purple cow, what to do when it's
your turn and it's always your turn.
He's founded companies.
His blog,
which you can find by typing Seth into
Google is one of the most popular in the
world.
In 2013 he was inducted into the
direct marketing hall of fame and he is
constantly shaking things
up and pushing the envelope,
testing the impossible.
Very, very brilliant guy.
And with all of that said,
please enjoy this round
two with Seth Goden.
Thanks Tim for having me.
What a pleasure to be back.
I will start by pointing out
how uh, erudite, intelligent,
good looking,
generous and thoughtful.
Most of the people who
listen to this podcast are,
I was optimistic that as we dive through
these questions and as Tim continues to
long arc of what he's
trying to talk about,
people will see over and over again.
And then in an economy
based on connection,
real connection comes from people who
seek to contribute to the community first
and that that asset, the trust
that comes from that is priceless.
So looking through these questions,
skipping the one about why I look like
a lizard and a few other questions that
have to do with um,
what it was like to be in a movie
with James Franco who I've never met.
So I've never been in a
movie with James Franco.
I find that there are a few groupings.
One gooping was,
uh,
talking about education and parenting.
Another grouping was the
mechanics of marketing.
And I would say the biggest grouping was
an understanding of the fear then each
of us has to deal with in
order to do this original work.
I tried alphabetizing the questions
in grouping. I've failed at that.
So maybe what I'll do is go through
them and as they prompt other thoughts,
I'll weave those together.
So it started with a James Roelof
who kicked us off with a question.
What's the one thing that
most marketers do wrong?
And this is easy. We're
selfish. We are narcissists,
infant tile narcissists who believed
that our need for more and our desire for
attention trumps everything else.
We justify and rationalize
our work and interrupt people,
spam people,
yell at people to save people and playing
the short term game again and again.
And again,
successful marketers are successful
because they don't do that.
And it turns out that that scares the
folks who are willing to build a story
that's true,
to earn permission to create a product
or service that spreads merely because
it's remarkable.
That mindset almost never shows up.
Next question from Paul Van [inaudible].
How do you build a tribe from scratch?
So the idea of tribes I think
is fundamental to humanity.
It's been around for thousands
and thousands of years,
but in the modern world in which we live,
we can get confused because it might seem
that our job is to build a tribe from
scratch, but most of the time
that's not what happened.
Nike did not invent the running tribe.
There were already runners
before Nike showed up.
Harley Davidson did not
invent the outside or tribe,
a group they called themselves the 1%
long before the other 1% showed up.
That what we do when we lead a tribe
often is we find people who are already
connected and we merely
show up to lead them.
And for most businesses, most
opportunities, we don't even lead them.
We merely serve as a
tribe that already exists.
So then when you find a group of people
who share an instinct and interest,
a connection, a leader, a goal,
and you give that group of
people something with which
they can take action to
where I BVH that long sentence is
people like us do things like this.
Once you were able to say people
like us do things like this,
then you have found a tribe that
can revolve around what you do.
Switching over to the fear side,
Jenny Western camp asked what limiting
self beliefs did I change in order to
become successful and how
did I change them? Uh,
this was actually work
that I did on myself, uh,
in college and have tried to continue
doing and myself for a long time since
then. The self limiting beliefs, in fact,
all of us because all of
us like being competent,
we like being respected.
We like being successful.
And when something shows up that
threatens to undo all of those things,
well then it's really easy to avoid it.
And what goes hand in hand
with that is the sour mindset.
The mindset of we're not
getting what we deserve.
The mindset of the world is not fair.
The mindset of why should I even bother?
It's probably not going to work.
And one thing,
those of us who were lucky enough to
live in a world where we have enough,
when we have a roof and we have food,
uh,
is we find ourselves caught in this cycle
of keeping track of the wrong things.
Keeping Track of how many
times we've been rejected,
keeping track of how many
times it didn't work,
keeping track of all the times someone
has broken our heart or double crossed us
or let us down. Of course, we can
keep track of those things, but why,
why keep track of them?
Are they making us better?
Wouldn't it make more sense to keep track
of the other stuff to keep track of it.